on va commencer par licorne le nikon qui
me regardait beaucoup sur france 4
au début sur des mythes et tu veux
m'adapter à mes complètement
bah non c'est pas la sava chéri
t'inquiète pas alors du monde compte et
non parce que voilà il écouté contre sir
et donald il était contre moi la télé
actuellement oui d'accord mais celle
donc tu voudrais quoi que je fasse quoi
du flipper tout sauf de la télé pour
éviter de voir ta tête d'accor abattant
des héros au nom mais on a demandé à
l'udc en devenir c'est elle dit ce
qu'elle pense voilà donc voila tu viens
cauchemar non j'ai pas un cauchemar je
suis super contente de pouvoir le dire
face à face et bah ça fait plaisir je
suis quelqu'un j'aime bien être franc
exactement j'aime bien montrer justement
ce que j'ai à dire parce que tu veux tu
vas nombreux tweets sur moi je le vois
chaque fois beaucoup
alors dis nous ce qui te dérange et à
petit nous pourquoi tu es contre moi à
la nar dix mois zada parce que je trouve
que les choses ont beaucoup changé
depuis le début des émissions
donc comme je disais je regardais tpm
fait depuis le début et au fur et à
mesure du temps ce qui s'est passé à des
beats et passe assez vite parce que bon
la chambre a changé de nom sur de plus
en plus moi je te tutoie pas ce que tu
est de la même génération que moi vous
mettez têtu vous regardez sur france 4
aussi ouais c'est ça mais même au niveau
de l'ambiance générale des chroniqueurs
il ya un malaise quoi mais bon il ya un
malaise complet mais maintenant tu dis
tu dis ce que tu dis est ce que tu
penses pas c'est plutôt les gens qui ont
changé par rapport à nous parce que
c'est un art mission a eu un énorme
succès et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de gens qui se sont intéressés à
l'émission et qu'on fait peut-être que
chaque chose qui se passait dans
l'émission devenez un énorme buzz alors
le buzz moi déjà je suis un peu contre
le faux buzz
oui mais dont l'effet que nous aimer les
uns les voyait beaucoup de journalistes
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle les plus
techniques
parce qu'ils savent que voilà ça fait
énormément parler pour faire des
articles contre nous c'est vrai qu'ils
font que forcément aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'on fait quelque
chose c'est beaucoup plus scrutés que
lorsqu'on était sur france 4 on faisait
du bois cent cinquante mille
téléspectateurs est un peu normal on
cherche tout ça on l'obtient non mais
non je cherche pas c'est vrai que moi je
trouve quand même que petit à petit au
niveau de ton comportement au nouveau sa
façon d'être des gros mots
ta façon
et nous on prend plus ferme où je gérais
cela me sert à ce racket dérange pas
tout où tous les regards
marc monfray remarque brad wall a tout
ça mais moi je comprends rien de quoi
justement ce que vous dites c'est la
différence par rapport à la première moi
je la regarde donc depuis 2010 depuis la
première et moi au contraire je vois
ensuite conducteur par rapport à la
première édition et je trouve que cyril
est le même
je vais même vous dire mieux l'émission
en fait je pense que c'est ce qui gêne
l'émission est devenue populaire et moi
populaire n'est pas un gros mot
contrainte c'est un mot que
j'affectionne et et c'est ce que disait
cyril vous pour avoir donc pour bosser
dans la communication et pour connaître
des journalistes qui bossent surtout
indigne et nous le disent quand on est
en ligne
il faut faire des il faut faire du clic
parce que c'est ça qui nous fait ramener
de l'argent et quand on fait un article
sur hanouna comme on fait un article sur
les pmp avec 1 1 avec un titre plus ta
clique ont fait de losail et c'est ce
que nous faisons c'est dingue et c'est
dingue mais malheureusement cela c'est
ça qu'on voit que tu m'as doit
malheureusement salariale si vous
regardez des articles généralement c'est
un micro événement vraiment un micro
événement et qu'ils enfants mais sachez
vous rapporter un triplé comme moyen un
journaliste qui m'a dit franchement tous
les jours il ya des artistes des
articles sur moi cyril hanouna au fond
du gouffre cyril hanouna wind et cyril
hanouna n'a plus d'amis j aimerais tu
fais ça il y est bon je te dis la vérité
dès que voilà je veux c'est juste pour
faire du clic parce que voilà des cons
mettons-nous avec un truc négatif à côté
ça ça ça cartonne
et le mec me l'a dit franchement je dis
beaucoup tu sais quoi continue alors si
on peut faire ton business là dessus -
la limite ça me dérange pas voilà c'est
tout si toutes ces petites choses qui se
sont greffés je suis en mesure du temps
ta façon d'être
terry redeviennent mais deviennent voilà
mais c'est sûr jouer ses droits réels
c'est pas vrai métier que j'ai toujours
quelque chose il faut que ça il ya quand
même une part de vérité
et si c'est trop sûr jouer les gens ils
se détournent pourquoi il ya moins
d'ambiance aujourd'hui ginola ou 2
toujours toutes les émissions et presque
deux millions on est amis en 3ème et oui
ma millions 3 ma chérie tu as tout les
jeux voices est à 10 millions il sera 3
millions ma chérie messaoud tombola non
mais tout le monde a baissé bon bah on
avait souhaité voir dit il a moins de
monde devant la télé mais en termes de
pourcentage
on fait toujours les mêmes audiences
depuis maintenant au séton on garde les
mêmes audiences depuis sept ans j'adore
balanced au poste et gentil je les
regardais depuis le tout premier numéro
tu vois franchement je trouve ces mais
ça me donne ma gueule d'ange de balances
ton bonhomme justement parler d'excès
mois elle s'arrête parce que pour moi
j'ai regardé à l'époque dechavanne
oisienne ou mardi ça me rappelle
énormément tout puissant que j'adorais
et fight entre les pour les tout ça
c'est très loquace à libérer les les
rats j'adore ce que je fais sur ip ah
oui ah oui j'adore mais le pourrai
faudrait un peu plus quoi on avait des
chroniqueurs j'en ai mis ko et pour les
balances ton post sincèrement vu que moi
je t'aime pas en tant que personnage
insurgés mercure regarde l'émission
quand même sélection pour les
chroniqueurs d'accord jimmy pour
christine alors justement bac aviez vous
restiez une toi tu es pour brosser
normal de tous bords oui alors moi déjà
je voudrais bien inviter licorne sous
effectivement la responsabilité de serre
et à le suivre quand même une petite
journée juste ont coulé le thurgovien tu
veux qu'elle meure ou qua non non c'est
non non non c'est intéressant de voir à
quel point il est exactement le même
avant et après le générique et ça fait
partie des raisons pour les galères
irdjen ça vous fait rire de vienne c'est
lui c'est une semaine avec moi non et
juppé rihouet non syrie
c'est du boulot malicorne pourquoi
est-ce que je suis là c'est justement
malicorne
c'est d'abord parce que j'aime son
personnage parce qu'il est généreux
alors bien sûr j'aurais pu aller sur
d'autres émissions avant mais j'ai aimé
sa générosité jamais je connais beaucoup
de patrons de chaînes de présentateurs
télé d'animateur de journalistes jamais
je n'ai vu quelqu'un jeudi avant même de
travailler avec lui
jamais je n'ai vu quelqu'un d'aussi
généreux avec son public a même quand
les juniors et m6 n'est pas là est ce
que je dis depuis le chauffeur de salle
inquiète pas non mais par exemple quand
la lumière s'éteint et parle au public
on n'est plus là il reste à parler avec
eux quand il ya la publie par le public
quand il ya des personnes en difficulté
va les aider quand les caméras sont
éteintes il va dans les hôpitaux voir
les enfants c'est ça qui me plaît chez
ce bonhomme que beaucoup ne comprennent
pas mais c'est ce qui me plaît chez lui
et c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
je suis là et que je le supporte
alors
[Applaudissements]